all right Calvin Johnson was one of the
great receivers of his generation he
only played nine seasons retired after
2015 at a time when his salary cap
number was about to spike to twenty four
million in early 2016 the Lions
desperately wanted to know what he was
going to do because they wanted to clear
those numbers off the books he
ultimately retired and then the line
said oh by the way you have to pay us
for the privilege of retiring of 3.2
million in unearned signing bonus money
the Lions eventually got back seven
figures roughly a million dollars and
now that they want to make nice with
Calvin Johnson Johnson over the weekend
at his youth football camp made it very
clear what the Lions have to do he said
they already know what they have to do
the only way they're gonna get me back
is to put that money back in my pocket
they can put it back then they can have
me back that's the bottom line and I
love the candor there is no hidden
agenda here there is no mincing of words
hey lions you know what you did you made
me pay back a million dollars
you shouldn't made me pay it back so if
you want to be my friend again give me
back my money yeah well you know first
off Calvin Johnson is a great guy I've
been around it before this is not a guy
that's like into doing this just for
doing it you know he's not trying to
like create headlines you know second of
all yeah I mean come on Detroit Lions I
mean I don't know why they ever like
forwarded with this disaster Calvin
Johnson other than you know Barry
Sanders and maybe Billy Sims I don't
know he's in the conversation from one
of the greatest lions of all time am I
wrong with that mic so you'd talk about
that and then - this is the thing I
think that bothers me about it and where
I really side with Calvin Johnson it's
not like he retired cuz he was like uh
I'm bored I'm gonna go retired and make
movies or you know become a writer for
you know you know rap songs or something
like that it's not like he went into
some business venture this is a guy that
dealt with a chronic knee issue
bone-on-bone every day of his life we
talked about him early at the show with
Todd Gurley Calvin Johnson at the end of
his career couldn't practice all he did
was suit up and play on Sunday because
yeah jamming his leg into the ground to
run routes had taken its toll eventually
so that's why he
to retire and that's where it's a bad
look for the lines and I don't blame him
for not coming around until they pay him
his money back when you mentioned Barry
Sanders I think the justification in
seeking money back from Calvin Johnson
is Barry Sanders was the original guy
paid back millions in signing bonus
because the idea is the signing bonus
isn't a lottery prize it is advance
compensation for future services to be
rendered and you earn that money in
every year that that signing bonus is
spread out the easiest example four year
contract with a four million dollar
signing bonus you earn that 1 million
per year at a time and so because they
took it back from Barry Sanders they
were able to justify taking it back from
Calvin Johnson but you know Johnson
should have just said I'm not retiring
carry my 24 million dollars under the
salary cap I'll show up and force you to
cut me and if he would have been cut not
only would have been able to keep the
money if he really did want to come out
of retirement there was some flirtation
about that a couple of years ago the
liens wouldn't have been able to try to
hold up someone for a draft pick be able
to go anywhere he wanted to go sign
whenever he wanted to sign and you know
that so I really do question I don't
know how much the agent was involved in
this planning the agent should have been
extremely involved yep and and there
should have been a strategy here for
making this work and you say to the
Lions he's not retiring cut him and if
you want him to retire we want two
things we want number one a you know a
guarantee that you're not gonna seek any
of his money back and number two if he
does choose to unretire you will
immediately release his rights so he can
go play for every wants to play for
otherwise we're gonna force you to go
through the indignity of cutting him
because we know you don't want to cut
him because your fans will be upset with
you if the headline is Lions cut Calvin
Johnson yeah you're exactly right Mike
and I mean when you wrote the article on
Saturday or whenever I read it on Pro
Football Talk I think it was Saturday I
mean yes if there's one area to blame
Calvin Johnson here yeah they could have
handled it differently certainly did not
have the right advice here from the
agent or whoever was around them as far
as how is the tackle this situation the
right way but regardless gosh damn I
mean the Detroit Lions come on for nine
years all you were was Matthew Stafford
in Calvin Johnson and it was just that's
all there was to it so there's a long
Dhamma consumer there - okay sure you're
exactly right I don't want to disrespect
him but there it was I mean it was those
three guys that carried the organization
they were the only names on the team and
yeah I just think it's a bad look when
you take money away from a guy I
understand he didn't earn it to that
point but it's not like I said he was
retiring because he just was like oh I
want to go sit on the couch and drink
beers he couldn't do it anymore his body
was literally falling apart he could not
run routes his knee had gotten to the
point where he was I don't think it was
literally falling apart I think there
was any zombie not contracted leprosy or
something like that but go ahead I'm
sorry I just you know they're just it's
bone-on-bone it's there's there's
meniscus issues there's all of that so
you know that's where I just I side with
the player and these kind of scenarios
and I I'm good for him for drawing a
line in the sand and saying no you're
not gonna get me back with like free
services so you can use me as a band-aid
to promote the Detroit Lions when you
took money out of my pocket and made me
pay you back for a lot of hard work and
the damaging of my falling apart knee
was due to me sacrificing my body for
this team on a weekly basis and jamming
my leg into the ground over and over and
over to run routes so I'm with now think
this goes over in the locker room in the
locker room I you know not then now
right now the players come together this
week for OTAs and they're talking about
that story how do they react to it yeah
they're gonna be like oh man you know
they don't mess you know they don't mess
around these these these Fords they
don't mess around you know they're
they're gonna ask for their money back
you know that it looks as almost a
little bit like you know they don't play
favorites with anybody and you're not
gonna get away with anything I don't
think there's gonna be other big issue
there but other than do they really
appreciate their stars I guess is what's
gonna be the big question in the locker
room well they could fix this very
easily Calvin Johnson has given them in
the path write a check to him for the
same amount of the check that he wrote
to you quick break more PFT live from an
a right
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports